WE HAVE HOURS NOW BEFORE IT IS
JUST OFFICIALLY ELECTION DAY.
BUT FIRST, WITH JUST HOURS OF
COURSE UNTIL THE FIRST POLLING
PLACES OPEN, PRESIDENT TRUMP, AS
YOU CAN SEE -- LOOK AT HIM!
HE IS JUST STILL WORKING HARD
FOR YOUR VOTE.
IN FACT, THE PRESIDENT STILL
RALLYING THE FAITHFUL IN
KENOSHA, WISCONSIN, WITH A FIFTH
RALLY TO, A LITTLE BIT LATER ON
TONIGHT.
WE HOPE IN THE SHOW.
THE MAN IS AN ABSOLUTE MACHINE.
BREAKNECK SCHEDULE.
IT’S A MEDIC OF HOW HE’S BEEN
RUNNING THE COUNTRY FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS.
AND IT REMINDS ME OF WHY THE
PEOPLE ELECTED HIM IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AND IT’S PAYING OFF.
CHECK OUT THE REAL CLEAR
POLITICS POLLING AVERAGES IN THE
KEY SWING STATES.
TRUMP IS AHEAD IN FIVE OF THEM
AND IS WITHIN STRIKING DISTANCE
IN THE OTHER THREE.
HE SWEEPS ALL EIGHT IF HE WINS.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT LEFT THE
HOSPITAL REMEMBER AFTER HIS
COVID DIAGNOSIS FOUR WEEKS AGO,
ALL THE EXPERTS ON THE LEFT IN
THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRAT POLITICS
SAID DON’T CAMPAIGN, IT’S TOO
DANGEROUS.
YOU WILL BE A SUPER-SPREADER.
TOLD HIM NOT TO HOLD RALLIES.
BUT HE KNEW HOW THIS WAS THE
MOST IMPORTANT ELECTION OF OUR
LIFETIME AND HOW IMPORTANT HIS
CAMPAIGNING WAS FOR THE PSYCHE
OF AMERICA.
HE HAD TO BE WITH THE PEOPLE.
THEY HAD TO SEE HIM.
HE KNEW IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR
AMERICANS NOT TO SUCCUMB TO THE
MEDIA AND THE BIDEN DOOM AND
GLOOM PROPAGANDA THEY’VE BEEN
PUSHING ON YOU SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PANDEMIC.
IN THE PRESIDENT’S FANS?
WHAT DID THEY DO?
HIS SUPPORTERS, THE VOTERS, THEY
REPAID HIM BY TURNING OUT IN THE
COLD, IN THE RAIN, IN THE HEAT,
IN THE WIND FOR RALLIES AND
IMPROMPTU CARAVANS.
THIS IS ALL ORGANIC.
IN ARIZONA, 1500 CARS TOOK PART
IN A PRO-TRUMP PARADE THAT
STRETCHED FOR MILES.
AND MILES.
CONSERVATIVES IN SAN DIEGO BUT
ON A HUGE BOAT PARADE, A LIBERAL
SEA OF TRUMP SUPPORTER’S, TENS
OF THOUSANDS TURNED OUT LAST
WEEK IN BUTLER, PENNSYLVANIA.
I PERSONALLY SHOT THIS VIDEO IN
OVERFLOW CROWD IN ROCHESTER,
MINNESOTA, AND THEN CHECK OUT
THESE CROWDS LAST NIGHT.
THIS IS IN ROME GEORGIA.
CHECK IT OUT.
THEN MIAMI OF COURSE, THIS IS
THE SCENE.
IT WAS A MASSIVE PARTY THERE AND
HERE’S TRUMP IN MICHIGAN EARLIER
TONIGHT.
AGAIN, HUGE CROWDS.
THAT CROWD JUST GOES ON FOREVER
AND EVER.
AGAIN, ORGANIC.
THIS IS AN ORGANIC MOVEMENT.
IT’S A LOVE FOR THIS PRESIDENT.
MEANWHILE, THE FAVORITE
CANDIDATE OF CHINA,
SILICON VALLEY, AND WALL STREET
IS OUT RANTING ON THE TRAIL AND
BEING PROPPED UP BY THE SAME OUT
OF TOUCH FORCES THAT FAILED
HILLARY IN 2016.
>> LADY GAGA.
NO OTHER NATION CAN TOUCH US!
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHO DONALD TRUMP
IS.
WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVERLIES,
CONSTANT LIES!
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT STRONG, HE’S
WEAK!
WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVERLIES!
>> Laura: GOSH, HE DOESN’T
SEEM SO CONFIDENT TO ME.
YOU COMPARE THAT TO TRUMP’S
FINAL RALLYING CRY, FOR HIM IT’S
ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
EVEN MORE SO THAN ABOUT BIDEN.
>> DO YOU WANT TO BE RULED BY
THE ARROGANT, CORRUPT, RUTHLESS
AND SELFLESS POLITICAL CLASS?
OR DO YOU WANT TO BE GOVERNED BY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THEMSELVES?
WE WILL NEVER BE A SOCIALIST
NATION.
IF I DON’T ALWAYS PLAY BY THE
RULES OF WASHINGTON AND THE
WASHINGTON ESTABLISHMENT, IT’S
BECAUSE I WAS ELECTED TO FIGHT
FOR YOU, AND I FIGHT HARDER AND
HARDER AND HARDER.
>> Laura: AND THAT IS TRUE.
FOR MONTHS WE’VE BEEN TOLD THAT
LIGHTNING CAN STRIKE TWICE.
BUT OF COURSE THE MEDIA ON THE
LEFT ARE MISSING WHAT’S
HAPPENING.
THE NATURE OF WHAT WE ARE
SEEING, THE CROWDS.
THE POP-UP CARAVANS.
LOOK AT IT.
IN BOTH PARADES, THE PASSION!
BOTH PARADES, WHEN DID THAT
START?
THEY ARE HAPPENING WHETHER THE
MEDIA REPORTS THAT ARE NOT AND
WHETHER THE LEFT BELIEVES IT OR
NOT.
AND WHATEVER HAPPENS TOMORROW
NIGHT, ONE THING IS COMPLETELY